it's a quiet
new year's day for 2021 and this
is my monthly and in this case
beginning of the year update for january
2021 i'm going to talk a little bit
about what went on in december
and what we've got coming up in january
and this is not going to be like a
review of the years or anything like
that i'm going to do that separately
this will just be for those
two particular months so i always like
to begin
with talking about three big things so
big
thing number one starting this month i'm
going to be bringing out some new
classes in
the study with sadler academy
all of them oriented around philosophy
in one way or
another so keep keep an eye out for that
in my
various social media some of you may be
quite interested in that people have
been saying they want to take classes
with me for a long time there's your
opportunity big thing number two
in the half hour hegel project due to
the work that i put in
this month of december we are now at the
cusp of moving from the spirit
section of the work where we've been for
a long time into
the religions section i'll talk a little
bit more about that
in the january section of this then
finally uh we have a new lineup for the
worlds of speculative fiction series you
can go to
my arrexis dno etiquette site or to
once i get it updated the class site for
the worlds of speculative fiction you'll
see
all the different authors who we're
going to do starting
with liu xi shin this coming month
of january so those are the big things
let's talk now about december
a lot of stuff going on in december as
always you know
holiday season approaching and
end of semester a lot of grading for me
and a lot of work for my my students i
did
happen to do a worlds of speculative
fiction
uh session on ursula k le guin we did
the the
book four book five book six of the
earthsea
trilogy and we had some great discussion
the video for that is linked if you just
click the show more
in the video description you'll see it
we also did my my usual
ama that is ask me anything uh
we did a political theory and
and practice discussion as well those
are online events that i do through
youtube
live i did my usual half hour hegel
q a and discussion one for the general
public one for
patreon supporters of the project
philosophy chat for some of my
my patreon supporters at the higher
levels
and we held our monthly mke sophia
that's society of philosophy in america
and our stoic fellowship meeting as a
matter of fact we just had our stoic
fellowship meeting
yesterday so that was a lot of fun
getting to see everybody
and of course wisdom for life radio show
has been airing
mostly reruns this last month because
dan and i only recorded one
one show on the paradox of choice but we
did do that
my classes as i mentioned ended this was
a grueling semester not just for my
students
but also for myself i had to do a lot of
content production in part
because i taught six different
classes a couple of which i didn't have
videos available for so i
shot something like
i don't know 300 new lecture videos over
the course of the semester
between world religions biomedical
ethics a few things they needed from
uh business ethics and a ton of content
for the existentialism class there there
was a lot of of new stuff that had to be
done so that that kept me pretty busy
i've been doing editing and writing
meeting with you know some of my
collaborators we had a end of the year
meeting for the the uh steering
committee for modern stoicism
and of course i did a lot of tutorial
work and some philosophical counseling
work with with clients
so that that always continues on
uh video wise i am very proud to say
that i
shot uh four half hour hegel videos
on the spirit section i didn't get to
the very end of the section
as i had hoped to but four is way better
than one or zero which has sometimes
been the case over this
last year due to busyness
i also you know produced a video for the
wisdom for life show that we did
i shot some saddlers stories i think
some of you may have enjoyed
those telling you a little bit about you
know things that happened in in my life
did a couple caption contests people
seem to have really enjoyed those
as well and i did one trolley problem
meme video that i'd been meeting to do
for quite a while
and i did some some core concept videos
on albert camus
myth of sisyphus and on franz fanon's
black skin
white masks on the podcast the saddlers
lectures podcast
by the way people who sometimes say is
there they have been doing a podcast for
about a year and a half now
um so in the sadler's lectures podcast i
i
made a vote and let people decide
um you know who i should do next so i
finished up with a de bouvoir
one's on ethics of no on on the second
sex
and heidegger was the hands down
favorite so i did some stuff on
heidegger's
what is metaphysics and then i did
podcast episodes on
fyodor dostoyevsky's brothers karamazov
primarily the the those two uh chapters
in book five
and i've started doing some aristotle um
podcast episodes on book two of the
nickel mccann ethics
um all of those i early release to my my
patreon supporters
so you know they get to see things a
little bit before
other people and that's that's it for
december
uh and that rounded out the the year
we have a lot of stuff lined up for
january so starting tomorrow that is the
second at 12
noon all of the times are central time
by the way because that's that's where
i'm based here in milwaukee
i will be having my monthly ask me
anything
ama session right so if you want to get
in on that
that'll be youtube live link to it is
below you can easily find it if you're
a a subscriber to this channel
if you turn your notifications on you
get notifications about
all the events i do later on that that
day
tomorrow at 2 p.m i'll have my
philosophy chat for patreon supporters
that's a perk that that i provide to
them it's a more intimate
video conferencing session they can ask
me about anything that they want to
and discuss things in more detail
on the third which is sunday
at 12 p.m i'm doing a philosophy pop-up
usually i don't announce these
in advance except to patreon supporters
but i'm going to do so
this time and this pop-up which will be
in youtube live
will be about making new year's
resolutions and
why i think resolutions are actually a
bad idea
and if you've made them you should break
them and replace them with something
else instead so you can tune in and find
out about that
on the ninth we'll have our
first worlds of speculative fiction
series
event of the year this will be session
48 in the series it's going to be
focused on
liutsi shins remembrance of earth's past
trilogy i might bring in some of the
other things that i've got by him
as well so that always begins with a
youtube video premiere
where we can do live chat and then
with a more intimate live discussion via
zoom afterwards so the the video
premiere
is at 12 o'clock the live chat
in zoom will be at 1 30 pm
then on the 13th a wednesday at 5 p.m
i'll have my public hegel q a
and discussion session underwritten by
my patreon supporters
but available to anybody who wants to go
if you've got questions about hegel
about german idealism about philosophy
in general or the themes that hegel
discusses like history
and you know human human development
come and we'll talk about it um on the
16th
at uh 12 p.m we'll be doing
the first classic metal class of the
year
we're going to be focusing some more on
the new wave of british heavy metal
which ran
you know you could say it began in 1980s
a good good starting point
we could say like 84 85 86 is is the
real
end of it if we want to include bands
like chrome molly in there
so that'll be you know a session between
me and scott tarrouli we'll be
discussing some new aspects about the
new wave of british heavy metal that we
didn't cover in the last
class session um on the
23rd i'll be doing a video premiere
about self-directed study
my advice for studying boethius somebody
who i'm teaching again
this term and then on the 24th
and i want to wait until later in the
month until after we have the
inauguration so we can see what happens
we'll be having our political theory and
practice discussion i haven't decided
what the topic will be
precisely but we'll see what happens
with the biden inauguration you know
i'm sure i'll have plenty of ideas then
finally on the 28th at 6 pm we have our
milwaukee stoic fellowship open to
people all over the world we've been
joined
by people from brazil from europe from
all
all sorts of other places so open to the
public we'll be discussing the
ninth and tenth chapter of antonia
maccarro's great book more than
happiness which is a comparative study
of buddhism and
and uh stoicism with a bit of aristotle
thrown in
here and there um i should remind you as
well that every saturday
at uh 4 p.m wisdom for life the radio
show that i do for
for river west radio with my co-host dan
hayes will be
playing worldwide you can you can go to
the site
click on the button to listen live and
you'll hear it
it won't be live every single time
they're going to be doing a few rerun
episodes but we are going to be doing
some new shows as well
coming up so you want to stay tuned
about that
and um what else to talk about so we've
got
videos coming up i'm going to be you
know
the events videos the you know worlds of
speculative fiction
ama all that sort of stuff will be in
there that you can watch
um video premieres uh you should stay
tuned for those as well
and i'm gonna keep doing some of these
personal videos like the sadler stories
the caption contest i might do some more
meme videos
if i get ambitious enough and i'm going
to be plugging away
at hegel i want to get back up to six
videos a month because i do want to
eventually finish this
half hour hegel project and we will be
crossing the threshold
into the religion section so that's
really cool
the spirit section of the phenomenology
is the longest one and it's taken us
several years to get through the
religion section
is not quite so long and so now we're
we're on the downhill grade
we're getting our way towards absolute
knowing
uh and hopefully we'll we'll conclude
the project by the end of the year
maybe we'll see how it works out
i'm going to be shooting some other
videos providing advice
to students of various sorts you know
like how to read a philosophical text i
know i did
that video years and years and years ago
on on how to do that i want to update
that
i want to talk about like how to avoid
plagiarism
what plagiarism is how to
you know reach out to your professors
and possibly go to get a
a decent response i'm going to do some
things like that i think
to help out students in academic
settings
and then i'm going to also be doing some
book reviews i've been putting those
off for a while i've got quite a few
books that i i need to do
sadler's honest reviews of and then
we've got core concept videos and the
core concept videos i'm going to be
doing some on boethius
obviously because i'm teaching the
consolation of philosophy
in uh
one or two of my classes i can't
remember quite uh
which which ones i've got it and i know
i've got it in the in boethius in
another class
um some foucault videos uh we're you
know one of the classes i'm teaching
this semester is philosophy mindfulness
and life and so we'll be talking about
um you know foucault's conception of
technologies of the self so i'll be
doing some work on that
and also some videos on pure ado
and some of his key ideas
about philosophy as a way of life
because that fits into that philosophy
mindfulness and life class
and that'll probably be it for the core
concept videos
this month and i may do some other
videos i don't know we'll
we'll see what happens podcast we got a
lot of stuff coming out i'm still
churning away at the aristotle
the other person who is in the vote who
i have to do some
some podcast episodes on is cicero and
i'm going to be doing them
on his his book on friendship
but i also need to do some on plato's
meno
i need to do some on parts of plato's
republic that i haven't gotten to
some other aristotle podcast
episodes on um
nico mccain ethics portions of that that
i'm going to be teaching this semester
so that'll probably take me
to the month and you know what else is
going on you know a lot of
standard work doing some writing
projects particularly with
some collaborators of mine
some of them are independent i'm going
to be writing more often in my medium
publication i'm starting an actual
publication
for myself what else you know i've got
philosophical counseling clients and
tutorial clients
people are asking me to come on for
interviews for podcasts
or shows or things like that so you'll
see some of that stuff coming out and of
course there's
stoicism today i'm still editing that
still part of the team and so i'll be
doing quite a bit of work
on that front as well and that that
takes me basically
through this thankfully long month of
january hope all of you had a great new
years
and you know hopefully 2021 will be a
better year
than 2020 was for for so many different
reasons
and hopefully i'll see you at some of
these online events
you